non
la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
le 13 mai dernier nous apprenions avec
une profonde tristesse le décès de notre
ancien collègue jean faure
profondément enraciné dans son vercors
qu'il aimait tant
il fut maire d'autres ans pendant un
quart de siècle
vice président du conseil général
conseiller régional
et en 1983 il fut élu sénateur de
l'isère le mandat qu'il exerça avec
exemplarité conditions jusqu'en 2011
pour lui notre assemblée était je le
cite une école de la vie il fut un grand
sénateur en témoigne affection que tous
ses collègues quelle que soit leur
appartenance politique lui porte et y
siégea son arrivée au sein du groupe de
l'union centriste et démocrate de
progrès puis en groupe de l'union
centriste et enfin au groupe ump
en témoigne également les éminentes
fonctions que lui furent confiés au
sénat secrétaire du bureau vice
président du sénat il présida à lui seul
plus de 2000 heures de séance et enfin
questeur
en témoigne enfin ces combats tout
d'abord au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques
puis au sein de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées
dans le livre retraçant sa vie le renard
du vercors il est écrit pour jean force
et attachement viscéral au village
d'autres en ce ver corps qu'il a souvent
conduit à sont éloignés pour pouvoir
mieux y revenir le renard du vercors
regagne toujours sa tanière
toute sa vie jean faure puisa dans cette
sagesse son humanisme dont nous gardons
le souvenir j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
rendre hommage le 18 mai dernier à
autrans au milieu de ces montagnes en
présence de ses proches des élus et de
sa famille j'aurais associer un moment
de recueillement qui nous allons
observer trois autres anciens collègues
qui malheureusement nous ont quittés
depuis la suspension de nos travaux en
mars
michel delebarre
et qui nous a aussi marqué ici
profondément dominique mortemousque la
dordogne et la ruralité
et yvan regard on nous gardons un
souvenir ici important homme de la
musique
comme de la culture
et qui fait lui aussi secrétaire du
sénat
avec un président que je connais assez
bien
je voulais que nous ayons une pensée
parce que ainsi va la vie mais je crois
qu'il est important que nous inscrivions
aussi dans la continuité de sept de ses
collègues dans leur diversité politique
ce bout de moments demande d'observer un
moment de recueillement
qui
madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
la séance est retransmise en direct sur
public sénat et sur notre site dans la
tradition du sénat et au nom du bureau
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges une des valeurs essentielles
pour deux au sénat le respect le respect
qu'il s'agisse du respect des uns et des
autres mais aussi plus prosaïquement le
respect du temps de parole salle madame
la première ministre des droits
inaliénables sur le temps de parole
qu'elle peut maîtriser
avec mesure mais voilà
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente sophie primas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
première ministre les français ont chaud
aujourd'hui mais ils ont peur d'avoir
froid cet hiver ils ont raison crise
énergétique sans précédent pas de gaz
russe une production nationale
historiquement basses d'électricité des
prix élevés c'est inquiétant pour les
ménages et pour notre économie de
production cette situation était
pourtant prévisible en février nous vous
alertons sur le probable black out et
nous avions formulé 12 recommandations
évidemment pas de réponse mais nous
avons surtout perdu 10 en dix ans de
politique énergétique qui s'est acharné
comme nous l'avons entendu ce matin à
détruire le monde haut d'hier avant de
construire l'énergie décarbonée de
demain exemple emblématique que la
fermeture de fessenheim 2 gigawatts dire
que nous rouvrons des centrales à
charbon quel échec pour le nucléaire la
ppe prévoit toujours l'arrêt de 12
autres réacteurs c'est contraire au
discours du président de la république à
belfort qu'en pensez-vous donc des
annonces aux actes pour cela et pour la
construction des nouveaux repères enfin
à court terme pour garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement il nous faut un
grand plan d'action depuis des années le
sénat demande la consolidation la
simplification de ma prive rénove des c2
l'accélération de la production de
biogaz la conversion bio carburant le
retour en grâce de l'hydroélectricité la
simplification des nerfs avec les
collectivités
madame la première ministre quelle est
votre feuille de route énergétique car
nous sommes un peu perdus devant tant de
revirements
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame agnès pannier
runes chimie liste de la transition
énergétique
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente prima nous sommes
aujourd'hui confrontés à une des prix
pires crises énergétiques depuis le choc
pétrolier des années 70 et nous devons
agir en conséquence à la fois à court
terme pour nous prémunir sur nos
approvisionnements en gaz et en
électricité et en tout cas sur notre
capacité à maintenir une capacité de
production forte en électricité mais
comment construire
l'électricité et le monde décarboné de
demain dont la canicule nous rappelle à
quel point il est urgent de s'y investir
face à cela nous agissons nous agissons
d'abord en mobilisant tous les moyens
pour
anticiper une possible interruption des
livraisons du gaz naturel russe
augmentation de stockage stratégique de
gaz naturel
capacité à réactiver la centrale à
charbon de saint-avold adam oui ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle mais c'est moins
de 1 % de notre production d'électricité
et je le dis on en aura peut-être besoin
au pic de l'hiver même si notre
préférence serait de ne pas avoir un
besoin plan de sobriété avec une
réduction de 10 % de notre consommation
d'énergie par exemple de notre chauffage
par exemple dans les bâtiments publics
dans les entreprises et j'ai mobilisé
avec mes collègues ministres chacun dans
leur domaine les entreprises et leurs
administrations pour faire cette
économie de 10% qui est absolument
nécessaire pour nous décarbonés et nous
passer des énergies fossiles et qui nous
permettront aussi de passer plus
facilement ces moments de crise
énergétique enfin nous n'avons rien
perdu notre ambition énergétique et de
réponse au réchauffement climatique
et ça vous l'avez dans le discours de
belfort qui est parfaitement clair
quatre piliers sobriété énergétique
réduction de 40% efficacité énergétique
rendre plus efficace encore les
dispositifs de conversion des véhicules
et de primes rénove et nous allons y
travailler avec christophe béchu et
olivier klein troisième pilier
accélération du développement des
énergies renouvelables
multiplication par dix d'une autre parc
photovoltaïque 50 parc éolien marin et
une loi sur l'accélération de la
transition énergétique pour bientôt
enfin dernier point évidemment le
nucléaire et sur le nucléaire nous
serons prêts tous rase tout cela sera
repris dans la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui nous
attend au contraire à venir et sur
lequel nous aurons eu l'occasion d'en
parler tout à l'heure dans notre rendez
vous madame la présidente
à la mamie nice nous espérons vous
croire mais ça fait dix ans que le sénat
lutte contre des trajectoires qui nous
semblent des fausses trajectoire et
qu'ils n'atteignent pas l'objectif et la
fermeture de fossés nam la réouverture
des centrales à charbon sont des
exemples de ce manque d'anticipation et
de cette fausse route sur l'énergie donc
nous voulons des énergies renouvelables
nous voulons des énergies décarbonées
nous voulons la sobriété mais maintenant
nous voulons des actes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue françoise
gatel pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole
monsieur
nationaux président monsieur le ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires les élus locaux
sont accoutumés aux crises de migraine
générés par la complexité des sujets qui
font leur quotidien toutefois
aujourd'hui l'art de la complexité a
atteint un sommet avec la mise en oeuvre
du zéro artificialisation net la
sobriété foncière est une nécessité que
personne ne discute mais justement parce
qu'elle s'impose à nous tous faut-il
s'assurer d'atteindre l'objectif or
monsieur le ministre l'absence même de
définition de la chose ap les âmes les
décrets d'application quasi kafkaïen qui
déforme l'esprit du législateur nous
conduisent collectivement dans une
impasse aussi monsieur milices ma
question est très simple accepterez-vous
la proposition du sénat de réviser les
conditions de mise en oeuvre du âmes
après l'hommage de madame la première
ministre à la sagesse inspirante du
sénat une réponse elle aussi empreinte
de sobriété comme la consommation
foncière sous la forme d'un oui sur un
très bon début monsieur le ministre
pour vous répondre pour vos débuts
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur béchu vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la présidente gatel
vous me permettrez de vous dire la joie
qui n'est peut-être pas partagé par tous
de me retrouver à nouveau dans cette
enceinte
je voudrais
je voudrais madame la présidente vous
répondre de la manière suivante la loi
kill my résilience du 22 août 2021 été
voté après une cmp conclusive de 12
heures et elle a permis à l'issue
d'arriver à la définition d'objectifs
communs dont je me réjouis que personne
ne les remettent en cause ce que vous
avez pointé c'est le fait que des
décrets pris le 29 avril un manque
d'accompagnement et de pédagogie
vis-à-vis des élus locaux
le risque
le risque le risque de disparités dans
l'application territoriale
amène aujourd'hui beaucoup d'élus non
seulement à s'interroger à mesurer leur
manque d'information le manque d'outils
pour être capable d'atteindre l'objectif
alors que encore une fois personne ne
remet en cause la nécessité de stopper
les 20 mille hectares
d'artificialisation parents que nous
constatons depuis quelques années la
première ministre ici même à l'occasion
de la déclaration de politique générale
a dit et a pris à témoin cette assemblée
de sa volonté de pouvoir vous associer à
chaque fois que cela sera nécessaire il
me semble qu'il ya peu de sujets autant
que lausanne qui sont aussi nécessaires
pour inaugurer cette coopération
fructueuse entre nous aussi dans la
continuité des échanges que j'ai eus
avant même votre question par le
président lugo par le sénateur blanc par
le président malhuret et par voie
l'instant de madame la présidente gatel
dont chacun sait le niveau de câblage
avec les associations d'élus partout sur
le territoire je vous invite très
officiellement à ce que nous puissions
nous retrouver pour que dans le respect
de l'objectif on réfléchisse aux
modalités à mettre en oeuvre et ce
peut-être à la réécriture d'une partie
des décrets qui ont été mis en oeuvre
pour éviter qu en visant un objectif on
en atteignent un autre
madame gatel
bon monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre c'est un bon début toutefois
moi je propose que collectivement nous
tirions des enseignements de la manière
dont nous fabriquons la loi d'abord
aucune loi ne devrait être étudié et
présenté au parlement sans une étude
d'impact complète et systémique pour que
la cohérence des politiques du
gouvernement soient respectés
deuxièmement monsieur le ministre il me
semble que nous pourrions être d'accord
sur le nécessaire contrôle de
l'imagination parfois débordante de ceux
qui écrivent les décrets d'application
et qui se prennent parfois pour le
législateur et enfin troisième fois
troisième point
troisième fois mais vous dis avait
répondu je pense qu'effectivement il
faut qu'on prenne la peine d'écrire
ensemble les choses avant si possible ça
éviterait de passer du temps à corriger
avec les associations d'élus mais aussi
que les sénateurs merci monsieur minutes
merci beaucoup sur collègues
non à paroles à notre collègue pascal
savoldelli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique mais
sa parole merci monsieur le président
madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres la sphère hubert
failli samedi au grand jour les conflits
d'intérêts entre le gouvernement et les
multinationales les relations entre
emmanuelle mâcon mise de l'économie de
l'entreprise hubert hubert n'est pas une
entreprise banal tout le monde le sait
ici elle a été déjà reconnu par la
fraude et par un modèle prédateur tout
ça dépasse le cas normal des relations
entre la puissance publique et les
intérêts particuliers de cette
entreprise si un ministre de l'économie
rencontres et échanges avec les
représentants d'intérêts il n'en
n'oublie jamais le sens de l'intérêt
général après la privatisation des
décisions publiques par les cabinets de
conseil mckinsey après black rock
premier gestionnaire d'actifs du monde
qui s'occupait de l'épargné des français
hubert aurait eu l'oreille du pouvoir
pour guider la casse du code du travail
dans le pays donc je sais pas qui va me
répondre dans les ministres mais
monsieur ou madame la ministre ma
question est simple vous pouvez vous
nous donner des garanties sur
l'indépendance des choix publics de
états vis-à-vis des géants de la finance
de leur influence heures et lobbystes
répondre la parole
et à roland lescure ministre délégué en
charge de l'industrie monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur savoldelli d'abord je voudrais
vous demander des excuses et bruno le
maire dont l'agenda n'a pas permis
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
mais mais
ça me donne
ça me donne d'autant plus
ça me donne mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'autant plus la chance de
pouvoir vous répondre et je suis très
heureux monsieur le président que la
première question gouvernement à
laquelle j'ai l'honneur de réponse ce
soit au sénat qu'elle ait lieu juste
après que la présidente sophie primas
est elle même pris la parole la
présidente sophie primas laquelle j'ai
eu l'occasion de travailler dans mon
mandat précédent elle m'a montré nous
avons montré qu'on peut travailler
ensemble avec le souci du compromis et
nous l'avons fait monsieur monsieur le
sénateur un ministre de l'économie
rencontre des agents économiques un
ministre de l'industrie rencontre des
agents de l'industrie et je le ferai
l'entreprise hubert vous l'avez dit
n'est pas une entreprise comme les
autres elle a d'abord une part de
lumière vous le savez monsieur parce que
dans le val de marne de nombreux gènes
ont grâce à hubert eu le pied à l'étrier
un premier pas vers un emploi pérenne et
ça vous le savez on leur doit mais on le
sait aussi cette entreprise monsieur le
sénateur elle a une part d'ombré vous
l'avez dit la fiscalité la précarité la
difficulté qu'on a parfois avoir de
l'information sur la manière sont dont
les données sont conservées par ces
entreprises il ya une chose que je peux
vous dire monsieur le sénateur c'est que
le ministre de l'économie de 2016 et le
ministre de l'économie qui lui a succédé
depuis 2007 n'ont jamais déroulé le
tapis rouge à cette entreprise qui a
poussé la régulation des géants du
numérique monsieur le sénateur c'est la
france qui a convaincu le monde de
mettre en place la fiscalité pour les
gérants du numérique c'est la france
c'est le président de la république
c'est bruno le maire donc monsieur le
sénateur nous continuerons à discuter
avec toutes les entreprises dont on
souhaite qu'elle s'installe en france
qu'elles créent de l'emploi en france
nous ne ferons sans concession dans la
transparence mais avec volonté merci
monsieur symbole de vie
oui merci monsieur le président tout
d'abord je voudrais informer mes
collègues que la question est grave et
avec solennité je vous le redis monsieur
le président notre groupe vous a écrit
pour qu'on puisse mettre en place une
commission d' enquête ou une commission
interparlementaire parce qu'entre la
réponse du président hier qui était une
non réponse avec de l'arrogance et de la
vulgarité est ce que je viens d'entendre
la vous en comprendrez monsieur le
président que nous voulons des éléments
de vérité vérifier ce qui est dit après
franchement vous manquez pas d'humilité
les gars femmes
243 milliards de bénéfices et vous nous
dites cocorico notre bilan est bon on a
fait ce qu'il fallait j'ai regardé
l'accord sur la taxation hubert api en
france cite le capital voyez j'ai des
bonnes références
2,3 millions d'euros vous savez ce que
dit journal le capital impôts
lilliputiens et vous nous dites que ça
marche votre méthode et que la
trajectoire elle est bonne et par
rapport à des jeunes de mon département
enfin vous les connaissez mur quoi vous
leur dites quoi hier dans le message du
président est ce que vous venez de dire
et moi ça m'a vraiment choquée c'est mon
milieu janvier un mois on peut pas dire
un jeune de la banlieue qui vit dans les
quartiers populaires c'est soit tu
restes dans ton quartier t'as rien voire
même tu peux être pris dans des éléments
extrêmement négatif qui détournent ou
alors c'est hubert mais ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire qu'on leur donne
quoi comme espoir de quoi d'avoir la
boîte noire l'algorithme d'avoir la
discipline craquelins tête contrôler
tout le temps non franchement
franchement c'est pas sérieux de
répondre comme ça et il ya un peu plus
de respect pour les jeunes des quartiers
populaires et ça donnera aussi le
respect aux jeunes des quartiers ruraux
où qu'ils soient respect respect
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole à d'autres collègues bernard
vue pour le gros du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je vais tenter par cette
question de sortir du pessimisme ambiant
certes la situation internationale est
difficile les conséquences sur le
pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français sont notables et les deux
projets de loi du gouvernement que nous
serons amenés à débattre ces prochains
jours sont des réponses concrètes et
immédiates aux défis que nous devrons
surmonter pour autant si l'énergie sont
bien là il ne recouvre pas totalement
notre ciel bien au contraire il y a des
bonnes nouvelles il faut aussi le dire
sur le front de l'emploi de
l'apprentissage mais aussi sur le front
notre industrie pour la troisième année
consécutive la france est le pays le
plus attractif d'europe nous creusons
même l'écart avec nos rivaux historiques
comme l'allemagne et le royaume uni
concrètement cela veut dire que notre
industrie a un avenir un avenir
international technologiques écologiques
numérique mais également une bouffée
d'air ce tour nos emplois la cinquième
édition du sommet shoes france ne fait
que confirmer cette reconquête
industrielle
c'est ainsi que quatorze entreprises qui
sont engagés lors de cet été pour un
montant global de 6 7 milliards d'euros
et la création de 4000 emplois pérennes
dans le pays je pense notamment à l'
usine de semi conducteurs à crolles en
isère qui permettra de créer 1000
emplois usine visité hier par le
président de la république
cette loi permettra aussi de réduire
notre indépendance vis-à-vis de l'asie
grâce à la fabrication de ces composants
électroniques un investissement inédit
pour notre industrie la reconquête
industrielle doit en effet être une
priorité de ce gouvernement pour
renforcer notre souveraineté économique
nous l'avons vu depuis la crise
sanitaire les défaillances de nos
chaînes de production avec les manques
de produits essentiels comme les
médicaments les masques les respirateurs
nous ont montré qu'il était urgent de
relocaliser une certain nombre de
chaînes de valeur ses faiblesses de tête
derrière nous et avec l'innovation la
régulation et la des corbeaux nation
nous pouvons continuer à transformer
notre industrie pour ce faire nous
constant sur d'autres détermination et
votre compétence monsieur le ministre
aussi pourriez vous nous indiquez votre
feuille de route pour faire de
l'industrie un nouvel eldorado
économique
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie monsieur lescure monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bernard
by merci pour votre question les
dernières 25 années on construit on
conduit un délai un déclin industriel
compenser inéluctable et que les cinq
dernières années ont permis d'enrayer je
tiens d'ailleurs à saluer ma
prédécesseure madame agnès pannier rue
nash et sur ce banc qui a contribué avec
le président de la république avec le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
mais surtout avec les industriels de
tous les territoires à enrayer le déclin
industriel français qui n'est pas une
fatalité vous l'avez dit le sommeil
france c'est un succès il a été un
succès lundi ça fait cinq ans qu'il
existe et en cinq ans c'est plus de 12
milliards d'investissements qui ont été
attirés en france qui ont créé de
l'emploi dans les territoires plus de
20000 emplois s'ils ont maintenu près de
200000 emplois et dans tous les
territoires y compris dans les
territoires défavorisés y compris dans
les quartiers populaires dont moi aussi
je suis issue monsieur le sénateur alors
vous m'interrogez sur la feuille de
route elle tient en un mot très simple
nous devons accélérer accélérer
accélérer à la fois en surmontant les
difficultés il y en a et en saisissant
les opportunités les difficultés d'abord
aujourd'hui dans l'industrie ya soixante
dix mille emplois qui sont non pourvus
nous devons former forme et requalifier
nous assurer que les jeunes aujourd'hui
qui sont exclues de l'emploi puisse y
avoir accès partout nous devons aussi
régler les problèmes de foncier parfois
installer une usine c'est difficile on a
installé plus d'usinés en france l'année
dernière qu'on n'en avait jamais
installé et on n'a surtout plus installé
qu'on en a détruit ont créé deux usines
en france aujourd'hui soyons en fiers
nous devons aussi accompagner les
entreprises en difficulté y aura des
situations difficiles et là dessus je
m'engage avec vous à avoir un langage de
vérité j'ai déjà échangé avec certains
d'entre vous qui ont des entreprises en
difficulté dans les territoires nous
travaillerons pour que les solutions
soient trouvées on n'y arrivera pas à
tous les coups mais sur les moyens nous
serons sans concession et sur la vérité
aussi nous avons aussi des saisir des
opportunités à saisir pardon pour
terminer vous l'avez dit sur la
transition écologique sur la création
d'emplois
sur l'exportation nous devons aussi
aller conquérir de nouveaux marchés à
l'international
les cinq derniers trous 30 ont été des
succès exceptionnels gageons que les
cinq divisions qui ont le seront
d'autant plus merci merci monsieur mini
fait donner la parole aux présidents
patrick kader pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains vous avez la
parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
première ministre dans le quinquennat
qui fait achevée vous n'avez pas voulu
augmenter les revenus du travail de
manière significative pour les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
plusieurs fois mon groupe a regretté sur
ses bancs des mesures prises sans
cohérence toujours trop tard toujours
sous la contrainte toujours le dos au
mur plusieurs fois sur ses bancs nous
vous avons demandé un rééquilibrage de
la fiscalité entre le travail et le
capital alors que vous l'avez sciemment
déstabilisé par un hyper bouclier fiscal
que même nicolas sarkozy votre nouvel
ami politique n'aurait osé imaginer au
moins un sujet sur lequel on peut vous
reconnaître une forme de constance temps
votre politique sur ce point toujours
favorisé les mêmes par un miracle
physique le ruissellement vers le haut
vers les plus aisés aujourd'hui vous
entamez un nouveau quinquennat marqué
par une situation économique inquiétante
aujourd'hui le mécanisme de
revalorisation automatique du smic n'est
plus suffisant pour compenser
l'inflation
c'est le moment de changer de méthode
renoncer à cette politique de fuite en
avant celles des chèques qui n'ouvre
aucun droit et à laquelle personne ne
comprend plus rien par ailleurs vous
vous présentez comme un gouvernement qui
est dans l'action et non dans
l'incantation alors je vous le dis
madame premier ministre les français ne
demandent pas l'aumône mais une juste
reconnaissance de leur travail pour
répondre à cette attente je vous soumets
à nouveau deux solutions justes et
efficaces la revalorisation du smic à
1500 euros et une grande conférence
sociale pour augmenter les salaires
pouvez vous madame bornes expliqué
clairement aux français pourquoi vous
vous opposez à ces deux propositions
au répondre la parole à madame la
première ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président caennais
nous le voyons tous les jours et nous en
sommes convenus lors de notre premier
échange la première priorité des
français c'est le pouvoir d'achat et
donc ce doit être notre priorité commune
depuis le premier jour mon gouvernement
est à l'action dans la continuité de ce
qui avait été menée par mon prédécesseur
jean castex depuis l'automne dernier
sous l'autorité du président de la
république et nous avons agi pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français je rappelle
que nous avons mis en place à l'automne
dernier les boucliers tarifaire sur le
gaz et sur l'électricité c'est le
blocage des prix du gaz au niveau de
l'automne dernier c'est la limitation de
la hausse de l'électricité à 4% et je
pense important que les françaises et
les français en soient conscients sans
ces boucliers tarifaire les factures
auraient explosé l'action que nous avons
menée c'est aussi la remise sur les
carburants sans cette remise le prix
d'un plein de 50 litres serait de 10
euros de plus et puis nous avons agi
avec l'indemnité inflation avec la
revalorisation du barême de l'indemnité
kilométrique avec une aide
exceptionnelle sur le chèque énergie
toutes ces mesures qui ont pu protéger
les français notamment les français les
plus modestes et ceux qui travaillent et
je voudrais le souligner monsieur le
président caennais l'ensemble de ces
mesures c'est 26 milliards d'euros
c'est considérable mais c'était
nécessaire pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français alors aujourd'hui
et je souligne aussi que grâce à ces
mesures nous avons l'inflation la plus
basse de la zone euro et nous avons la
chance en france d'avoir un salaire
minimum indexé sur l'inflation et le
pouvoir d'achat donc qui progresse et
qui progressera à nouveau au 1er août
prochain mais par ailleurs il faut aussi
agir pour l'ensemble des français on
sait que la guerre en ukraine dur les
perspectives économiques s'assombrissent
les prix continuent à monter donc nous
voulons prendre de nouvelles mesures
pour protéger les français c'est tout le
sens des textes sur le pouvoir d'achat
qui sont en cours d'examen à l'assemblée
nationale vous aurez prochainement a
examiné dans le cadre de ses projets de
loi nous proposons de prolonger des
boucliers tarifaire sur l'énergie
d'augmenter les revenus du travail et de
mieux partager la valeur par exemple
avec une baisse de charges pour les
indépendants avec un triplement du
plafond de la prime de pouvoir d'achat
de revaloriser les retraites
les prestations sociales d'aider les
travailleurs pour lesquels la voiture
est une nécessité
donc nous voulons agir globalement pour
l'ensemble des français je vous ai
présenté nos propositions nous voulons
en débattre avec le parlement mais nous
serons attaché dans les discussions à
venir à ce que nos propositions soient
efficaces c'est à dire qu'elle se
traduise par un impact rapide pour les
français qu'elle soit responsable
nous voulons encourager le travail nous
devons aussi préserver l'équilibré de
nos comptes publics et par ailleurs nous
devons agir en cohérence avec l'urgence
climatique et puis équitable parce que
nous voulons d'abord protéger
effectivement ceux qui soufflent
souffrent le plus de cette inflation
donc voilà le sens de notre action pour
les français hal gill agir vite et agir
fort et je suis convaincu qu'ensemble
nous y parviendrons
monsieur le président d'euros kader
madame le premier ministre vous n'avez
pas répondu je suis désolé j'entends
bien toutes les mesures que vous évoquez
d'ailleurs qui coûte très cher au budget
de l'état il faudra abandonner savoir
comment nous réglons la dette de la
france en la matière ma question est
simple quels efforts demandés vous aux
employeurs dans ce pays votre ministre
de l'économie des finances qui n'est pas
là aujourd'hui sûrement pour une bonne
excuse ça fait trois ans qu'ils
demandent aux patrons permettez moi
l'expression augmenter les salaires avec
quels résultats c'est de l'incantation
quand vous nous dites vous allez
augmenter le smic j'entends bien 26
euros madame 26 euros pour un smic 2302
euros aujourd'hui voilà la réalité les
français encore une fois ne demande pas
le monde ils demandent pouvoir vivre de
leur travail dans de bonnes conditions
et dans la dignité
la parole est mana aeternam la
présidente nathalie delattre pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole même
la présence monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire je me
fais la porte parole de l'association
nationale des élus de la vigne et du vin
pour vous souhaiter la bienvenue dans
votre nouvelle fonction au cours du mois
de juin
dix jours de grêle ont ravagé trente
mille hectares de vignes sur l'ensemble
des terroirs français en passant de la
gironde à la lozère ou chez mes
collègues l'hérault par exemple vous
l'avez d'ailleurs constaté lors de votre
venue en gironde le 6 juin dernier les
viticulteurs sont désemparés la
viticulture française est sinistrée nous
ne savons plus comment faire face à
l'accumulation des difficultés
la crise diplomatique avec les états
unis la crise qu vide avec la fermeture
des bars et des restaurants
la crise climatique la crise
inflationniste face à ces innombrables
défis les viticulteurs ont besoin d'un
soutien massif du gouvernement
j'ai une pensée également pour nos
civils culteurs élus et pompiers
girondins qui se bat depuis hier soir
sur le front de trois incendies
dévastateurs et je remercie le ministre
darmanin de s'y rendre tout à l'heure à
court terme il semble inévitable de
mettre en place un fonds d'urgence pour
venir en aide aux viticulteurs mais plus
largement aux agriculteurs dont la
trésorerie a disparu par cette
succession de crises nombreux
agriculteurs ont souscrit un pg e mais
la situation actuelle transforme son
remboursement en véritable couperet
l'allongement généralisée des délais de
remboursement des pge est la seule
solution pour ne pas mettre les
exploitations les plus en difficulté en
cessation de paiement enfin de
reconnaître le travail du gouvernement
dans la réforme du dispositif
assurantiel de gestion des aléas et le
travail de notre collègue henri cabanel
mais il est vain
si le mode de calcul des références de
production historique basé sur la
moyenne olympique que si on ne permet
pas de tenir compte de l'enchaînement
des aléas ayant frappé nos terres ces
dernières années alors monsieur le
ministre quels sont les annonces que
vous pouvez nous faire ici aujourd'hui
pour prévenir les drames familiaux et
entrepreneuriaux à venir merci monsieur
le ministre marc fesneau médis de
l'agriculture la souveraineté
alimentaire
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice madame la présidente
de l'ate remercie de votre question
j'aurais tout d'abord m'associer aux
propos que vous avez tenus sur les feux
de forêt qu'ils sont actuellement en
cours en gironde- gérald darmanin comme
vous l'avez dit va s'y rendre j'imagine
qu'il interviendra là dessus mais
simplement vous dire et salué le travail
des sapeurs pompiers des soldats du feu
des forces de sécurité civile des
gendarmes des policiers des élus locaux
qui sont particulièrement mobilisés en
ce moment alors que nous sommes qu'en
début de période et que malheureusement
la sécheresse et la canicule fait rage
et doom permettrait de faire un appel
aussi à la citoyenneté de chacun et
chacun entre chacune et chacun d'entre
nous près de 90% des incendies sont
d'origine humaine et donc nous
permettrait faire un appel à la
vigilance de chacune et chacun d'entre
nous dans nos actes me posais la
question des épisodes de grêle qui se
sont déroulés en particulier dans votre
département les 4 et 5 juin qui
malheureusement se sont prolongées
plusieurs jours et même plusieurs
semaines durant plusieurs dispositifs
sont à l'aise je suis effectivement
aller le 6 juin pour me rendre contre
pour faire état de la situation premier
élément on est bien sûr un dégrèvement
de la taxe sur le foncier non bâti comme
ces deux coutumier si je peux dire
deuxièmement report des cotisations trop
social troisièmement les calamités
agricoles là où elles peuvent
s'appliquer malheureusement sur des
sujets comme cela cela ne va pas
vraiment s'appliquer deuxième élément de
réponse sur les plaies garantis par
l'état en particulier les prêts garantis
par l'état dit résilience je vous
confirme que dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui sera proposé
et débattu à l'assemblée puis au sénat
il est proposé la prolongation et donc
c'est un outil qui me paraît utile pour
cela troisième élément g délit
dirigeante et une mission d'inspection
express dont j'aurai les résultats la
semaine prochaine parce que la nature
des événements leur ampleur et en même
temps leur intensité variable selon les
secteurs nécessitent que nous
réfléchissions à des dispositifs très
adapté secteur par secteur ça a touché
de la viticulture ça a parfois toucher
l'arboriculture ça parfois touché les
grandes cultures d'autres secteurs et
donc faut qu'on adapte les outils au
mieux et sous l'autorité de la première
ministre on mettra
les dispositifs qu'il faut en place le
tas a toujours été au rendez vous ces
dernières années ça l'a été sur le gel
enfin sur système assurantiel l'objectif
c'est bien de le mettre en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2023 avec le sujet de la moyenne
olympiques mais déjà de le mettre en
oeuvre et travailler au niveau européen
sur le sujet de la moyenne olympiques
parce qu'on sait c'est un système qui
peut être pénalisant pour un certain
nombre d'agriculteurs qui ont été avec
plusieurs épisodes de calamités merci
beaucoup
la parole est à notre collègue raymonde
poncet monge pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé faut-il confier le
ministère de la santé à des médecins la
question est légitime quand on constate
le risque accru d'effondrement de
l'hôpital public les sépare votre
confrère du moins à des médecins peu
soucieux d'y défendre le service public
universel de qualité votre traitement
d'urgence fait de nouveau la part belle
au libéral en démultipliant les
différences de rémunérations entre ceux
qui exercent et reste à l'hôpital
assurant coisy seule la pénibilité de la
permanence des soins et ceux pour qui
vous ne mettez aucune obligation à
prendre enfin leur part mais à qui vous
octroyer des surrémunérations horaires
creusant le différentiel dégradant
l'attractivité de l'hôpital et
alimentant des missions et vacances de
postes votre diagnostic est vraiment un
complet il omet l'absence de lits
d'hospitalisation pour par exemple aux
urgences pédopsychiatrique hospitalisés
les enfants à laval en détresse
psychologique car vous continuer à
fermer des lits votre préconisations
principale concerne le tri des patients
à l'entrée des urgences alors que les
samu sont déjà débordés que 10% des
postes d'assistants de régulation
médicale sont vacants dans le 93 depuis
que l'on encourage appeler le 15 seuls
8% des appels peuvent être décrochés
dans la minute un psychiatre appelle
cela déplacé le symptôme plutôt que sous
traiter la maladie
rouvrez des lycées la 43e deuxième
proposition ma question est simple ces
mesures dites d'urgence un script elle
dans votre vision des urgences réduite
aux seuls urgent vital ce qui n'est pas
notre conception ou si l'été de tous les
dangers passé vous allez enfin consentir
à nous présenter à l'automne un budget à
la hauteur des besoins de santé des
populations et de nos territoires
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de la santé de la
prévention françois braun vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président mesdames et les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice poncet monge ma
mission vous le savez en tant que
ministre de la santé c'est de permettre
à chaque français d'être pris en charge
de manière adéquate lorsque cela est
nécessaire
et ça ne se limite pas bien entendu à
l'urgence vitale vous l'aurez compris je
tout d'abord couper court à ce que
j'entends parfois oui chaque français
continuera bien entendu à être pris en
charge dans le cadre de l'urgence et des
soins non programmés
là où ce sera le plus utile pour lui en
aucun cas jde préconisé et je ne
préconise la fermeture de services
d'urgence le terme triage et est
particulièrement utilisé mais
particulièrement mal utilisées nous
professionnels nous préférons le terme
de qualifications qualification de la
demande du patient ou de sa famille et
en fonction cette qualification
l'orientation vers le parcours de soin
le plus adapté j'ai l'habitude de le
dire quand on a mal aux genoux depuis
trois semaines il vaut mieux aller voir
son médecin traitant ou un médecin
généraliste à côté plutôt que d'aller
voir un service d'urgences nos services
d'urgence qui font face à une tension
qui n'est pas seulement liée à leurs
difficultés ou difficultés de l'hôpital
mais un enjeu systémique global
d'organisation de l'offre de soins c'est
dans cette perspective globale que nous
travaillons vous l'avez compris
transformation d'un système basé sur
l'offre de soins vers un système qui va
être basée sur le besoin de la réponse
aux besoins de santé de nos concitoyens
je ne reviendrai pas sur toutes les
quarante et une mesure vous en proposer
madame la sénatrice une 42e qui est de
rouvrir des lits je vous rejoins
totalement mais pour ouvrir des lits il
faut des soignantes pour avoir des
soignants il faut qu'ils reviennent à
l'hôpital pour qu'il revienne à
l'hôpital il faut qu'ils retrouvent du
sens dans leur métier et c'est un
objectif important de redonner du sens
dans ces métiers
j'ai signé vendredi dimanche par dont
l'instruction aux ars pour reprendre
l'ensemble de ces mesures d'urgence ou
dit quel privilège il le secteur privé
je m'inscris en faux ces mesures ont
deux éléments principaux pour la
première fois on reconnaît la notion de
pénibilité et en particulier la
pénibilité du travail de nuit c'est une
porte ouverte bien entendu une fois les
plus loin et en ce qui concerne la
permanence des soins vous aura pas
échappé que nous préconisons que cette
permanence des soins soient partagées
entre le secteur privé et le secteur
public en fonction des spécialités
pourquoi parce qu'on ne peut faire pour
reporter sur le secteur public seul
cette pénibilité de la permanence des
soins
donc vous l'aurez compris pour le lait
est de faire travailler tout le monde
ensemble les soignants les soigner les
élus le privé et le public ensuite en
quittant les silos qui existent jusqu'à
présent
d'un pansement jeu avec quelques
secondes
monsieur le ministre de la santé un
indicateur simple jugera de vos
promesses nous avons deux cent mille
infirmières qui ont quitté leur métier
pour ne pas être mal traités pour ne pas
être mal traitant donc soit l'hémorragie
continue soit ce que vous venez de dire
vous le traduisez dans les politiques
publiques de santé
la parole est à notre collègue jean
louis lagourgue pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
merci monsieur vous avez la parole remy
nice et outre-mer appelé après plus de
deux semaines de mobilisation
négociations dans le cadre de la
nouvelle convention canne les planteurs
réunionnais ont enfin obtenu gain de
cause hier soir je vous remercie d'avoir
pesé du reste du tout votre poids aux
mener à bien cette négociation c'est la
fin de conflit il y aura duré longtemps
bien trop longtemps comme c'est le cas
malheureusement à chaque renégociation
de cette convention depuis plus de 20
ans si un agriculteur résignés on s'y
retrouvait un accord global sur les six
prochaines années il n'en demeure pas
moins que les acteurs de la filière
reste très inquiet pour l'avenir de leur
profession
sur plusieurs points ils n'ont pas
obtenu satisfaction notamment sur le
fait que l'industriel tereos refuse
toujours d'adopter à la réunion le même
modèle coopératif qui l'appliquent en
métropole
et qui garantit une meilleure
répartition des richesses
les planteurs aurait également que
l'état ne les acomptes pas davantage au
moins le temps de la conjoncture
actuelle peu à faire face notamment aux
prix des intrants landré par exemple qui
a été multiplié par trois ces derniers
mois enfin ils réclament toujours que le
prix de la bagasse la prime bagasse soit
revalorisé cette prime actuellement de
14 5 euros par tonne de cannes n'a pas
évolué depuis 2015 alors que pour des
énergies polluantes telles que le
charbon le prix est passé de 80 à 400
euros
regarde ses inquiétudes légitimes et des
enjeux cruciaux qui en découlent
j'essaie très savoir monsieur le
ministre quelles actions pérennes vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre pour
sauvegarder cette filière calme qui
demeure plus que jamais au coeur d'une
économie circulaire employant de nos
territoires ultramarins des milliers de
nos concitoyens
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes délayé chargé d'être aubert
jean françois caraco vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre le président du
sénat madame la première ministre
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je suis
effectivement très content vous me
posiez cette question aujourd'hui
puisque pas plus tard qu'hier
l'assemblée nationale nous étions
accusés de ne rien faire que ça
n'arriverait jamais c'est arrivé
aujourd'hui et j'ai assisté à la
signature de cette convention qui règle
les affaires jusqu'en 2027 à la grande
satisfaction des planteurs de canne des
romier des industriels et pour la
première fois j'ai tenu avec la présence
de madame la présidente du conseil
régional et du président du conseil
général
c'est une avancée considérable qu'ils
essayaient tout cela ensemble
tout le monde a fait des efforts
significatifs
alb ioma pour revaloriser la prime
bagasse 3 euros de plus pour les
planteurs les planteurs et tereos pour
aboutir à une répartition équilibrée des
bénéfices nous avons été chercher les
bénéfices accumulés de tereos pour les
remettre dans la convention et pour
répartir les bénéfices ses bénéfices il
ya dans le même temps l'état augmenter
l'aide aux planteurs de 14 millions
d'euros et confirmer l'aide à
l'industriel de 28 ans le résultat est
sans commune mesure puisque pour la
première fois le prix d'achat de la
canne pourra être
supérieur à 100 euros par tonne soit 15
euros de plus que lors de la précédente
convention j'affirme que les gagner les
planteurs de canne qui était la clé avec
qui j'ai assisté à cette signature était
content sur la signature particulière de
tereos à la réunion je répète ce que
j'ai dit hier à l'assemblée nationale je
travaillerai avec les autres ministres
concernés à renforcer la transparence
la transparence de ce groupe dans ses
activités à la réunion sur le coût des
intrants fin et plus largement sur les
conséquences du conflit en ukraine des
mesures ont déjà été prises la prise en
charge des cotisations sociales pour
2022 ou 2023 ce n'est pas rien une aide
exceptionnelle
du feader a mobilisé par le conseil
départemental de la réunion qui était là
présent pour confirmer son accord le
musicien d outre-mer ministère de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire vont désormais travailler
sur la souveraineté alimentaire
production animale production de fruits
et légumes les premières discussions que
j'ai eues avec le ministre chargé des
comptes publics
l'espérait fermement une évolution
positive pour l'ensemble des dom
sur la gorre quelques secondes n'ont
donné la parole à madame la présidente
catherine de roche pour le groupe est
républicain
merci à monsieur président à ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé et
pour vos premières cuvées monsieur le
ministre a eu des tas de questions à
vous poser qui concerne notre
connaissance des affaires sociales
néanmoins mon propos concernera les
maternités la semaine passée je me suis
rendu à l'hôpital delafontaine à
saint-denis en seine-saint-denis où j'ai
voulu rencontrer les équipes de la
maternité et voir comment se préparer
l'été il s'agit d'un établissement de
niveau 3 qui fait plus de 4000
accouchements par an et qu'il prend en
charge notamment des grossesses à risque
et je pense aux femmes atteintes de
drépanocytose
le constat que nous avons fait accablant
sur 91 femmes 30 manque un tiers nous
avons traversé un service de
néonatologie
avec le service des soins intensifs
quasiment vide 3 berceau sur 20 avec où
chacun se démène pour essayer de trouver
des places pour envoyer les nouveau nés
dans des établissements qui sont à
proximité sauf qu'eux aussi sont en
situation de tension vous êtes mini de
la prévention la prévention est
complètement laissés de côté donc ma
question est simple que souhaitez vous
faire pour que les concernant les
maternités les femmes d'île de france
mais partout en france puissent
accoucher en toute sécurité ce qui n'est
pas le cas comment souhaitez-vous
comment pouvez-vous faire revenir des
sages femmes puisque ce sont surtout les
personnels qui manquent les sages-femmes
dans les hôpitaux et on nous a signalé
que les recrutements de sages-femmes à
diplôme hors union européenne est
beaucoup plus conteste que celui des
praticiens les pas du hors sages-femmes
et praticiens sont des professions
médicales je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
pour vous répondre
la parole est oubliée de la santé de
prévention monsieur brawn
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la présidente de
roche oui vous avez raison le problème
de santé et systémique ce n'est pas que
la crise conjoncturelle que nous vivons
actuellement mais c'est bien sur
l'ensemble du système de santé qu'il
faut faire peser nos efforts notre pays
connaît depuis plusieurs années une
réorganisation continue des maternités
sous l'effet des ja de contraintes de
démographie médicale mais aussi et
surtout dans le cas des exigences de
sécurité et de qualité des soins que
nous devons à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyennes des inégalités persistent
je vais lutter contre celle-ci comme
d'ailleurs contre toutes les inégalités
d'accès à la santé d'une façon générale
en réponse à ces constats nous agissons
déjà pour mieux prendre en charge les
femmes dans nos maternités avec le
déploiement en cours de maisons de
naissance huit maisons de naissance
expérimental en voie de pérennisation
pour une cible de 20 ans à court terme
le projet d'extension des missions des
centres périnataux de proximité pour
apporter une réponse au plus près des
territoires étendre ses actions dans le
champ de la santé de la femme et de
l'enfant l'expérimentation des équipes
mobiles de néonatalogie admissibles la
mise en place pour les femmes issues de
territoires isolés de la prise en charge
d'un hébergement de proximité à la
maternité la prise en charge également
de fêtes de frais de transport nous
renforçons également l'attractivité des
métiers du soin notamment pour les
maternités je pense notamment la
question de l'exercice mixte ville
hôpital pour les sages-femmes ont parlé
de faire revenir les sages-femmes à
l'hôpital les sages femmes avec qui j'ai
discuté quitte l'hôpital par la
pénibilité aussi de la permanence des
soins je le répète cette pénibilité de
la permanence des soins ne doit pas
porter seulement sur l'hôpital public et
doit être partagé entre le public et le
privé les professionnels exerçant
maternité ont par ailleurs bénéficié de
12 millions d'euros de valorisation
ségur des sages-femmes également ont une
revalorisation complémentaires portant
la hausse de revenus à 500 euros par
mois en moyenne nous poursuivons aussi
des actions pour développer nos
capacités de formation de ses métiers
ses spécialités par l'ouverture de
places la fin du numerus clausus bien
entendu la sixième année d'études de
maïeutique par exemple en outre pour
soutenir les professionnels des
maternités et dans la tente des travaux
menés dans le cadre de la conférence des
parties prenantes il vous a pas échappé
que les mesures de la mission d'urgence
ou dit flash s'applique à l'ensemble des
professionnels en particulier conclut
c'est à ceux des maternités
hommes la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre vous m'avez
répondu en effet sur certains points
mais quand on aime grossesses à risque
que c'est pas dans une maison de
naissance donc il ya vraiment vraiment
un problème urgent dans ces maternités
et les personnels que nous avons vu
qu'ils sont formidables de dévouement
mais qui sont aussi empreint d'un
désespoir total ce personnel nous disent
bien si on revenait déjà la situation
intérieure qui était déjà une situation
complexe et difficile de sous-effectif
ça irait mais sont bien ans de cela de
ces situations bon vous ne m'avez pas
répondu sur les diplômes étrangers on
peut pas
balayé tout le sujet nous vous donnons
rendez vous à la rentrée après la
session extraordinaire dès le mois de
septembre pour voir avec vous bien
d'autres sujets avant l'examen du plfss
merci madame la présidente
donnait la parole à madame la présidente
laurence rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
merci merci monsieur le président il y a
6 mois le président macron devant le
parlement européen a indiqué son souhait
d'inscrire le droit à l'avortement dans
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne et nous avons été
nombreux et nombreuses applaudir à ce
moment depuis il ya eu l'effroyable
décision de la cour suprême aux états
unis qui a été pour nous un choc brutal
aucune démocratie n'est désormais à
l'abri le lobby international anti ivg
anti choix et puissant il dispose de
moyens financiers importants de relais
idéologiques politiques et religieux
personne ne peut dire ce qui se passera
en france demain ou après demain
plusieurs propositions de loi ont été
déposées et j'associe dans mon propos
mes collègues du groupe communiste les
collègues du groupe europe ecologie les
verts qui oscille travail ainsi que tous
les groupes de l'assemblée nationale
mais la conscience 58 est ainsi faite
que ce n'est pas le parlement qui a la
plus facile d'initiatives en matière de
réforme de la constitution
la démarche la procédure la plus
efficace c'est celle du projet doit
aussi madame la première ministre ma
question est très simple et je vous
demande solennellement pensez vous
inscrire à l'ordre du jour un projet de
loi pour un sport définitivement
garantir dans la constitution le droit à
l'avortement et à la contraception
pour vous répondre la parole est au
garde des souvenirs de la justice
monsieur dupont moretti vous avez la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
rossignol l'histoire fourmille
d'exemples de libertés fondamentales que
l'on croyait acquise et qui ont été
balayés comme tu autant de fétus de
paille l'exemple américain nous rappelle
que même dans les grandes démocraties ce
que l'on croyait acquis depuis 50 ans en
réalité ne l'est pas le droit tally vg
est un droit fondamental
bien sûr et personne je dis bien
personne ne peut envisager de retirer
aux femmes le droit de disposer de leur
corps c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république et vous
l'avez rappelé en janvier avant même la
décision américaine indiqué qu'il
envisageait de l'inscrire dans la charte
des droits fondamentaux de l'union
européenne
c'est la raison pour laquelle madame la
première ministre elle aussi a dit que
le gouvernement soutiendrait toutes les
initiatives parlementaires engagés sur
cette question je pense à la proposition
de loi de la présidente bergé mais en la
matière madame la sénatrice toutes les
volontés sont bonnes à prendre et je
sais nous savons tous ici votre
engagement en la matière alors certains
diront et vous l'avez rappelé que le
l'exemple américain n'a pas sa place en
france en réalité on va le dire rien en
la matière n'est jamais acquis la
liberté la démocratie les droits
fondamentaux sont toujours fragiles et
mérite notre vigilance nos institutions
fonctionnent c'est vrai différemment le
droit à lille et j'ai ici mieux protégés
et je sais que ma collègue isabelle rome
se bat au quotidien pour donner à toutes
les femmes un égal accès à l'île et g
mais de grâce et vous l'avez dit ne
prenons pas de risques c'est pourquoi en
tant que garde des sceaux je soutiendrai
avec force ces initiatives pour les voir
aboutir le parlement est dans son rôle
le gouvernement sera dans le sien pour
qu'enfin le droit à l'ivg et devienne un
droit inaliénable
adam rossignol même le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux je me
réjouis du fond de votre réponse mais
n'en prenez pas ombrage je vais
m'adresser à la première ministre rien
de personnel monsieur le garde des
sceaux soyons en certains madame la
première ministre j'ai cru comprendre
que vous cherchiez des majorités de
projets je vous en propose une à cet
instant une belle majorité de projets
qui vous permettrait sur un projet de
loi et pourquoi j'insiste sur le projet
de loi parce que la procédure parle
d'initiatives parlementaires n'aboutira
pas personne ne veut un référendum sur
l'axé arrivé j'ai donc la seule solution
pour que vos engagements soit concret
pour que votre mandat à matignon ne soit
pas simplement le mandat d'une deuxième
femme première ministre mais celui d'une
deuxième femme première ministre qui a
fait avancer les droits des femmes je
vous le redemande fait un projet doit
merci la parole
à notre collègue jean baptiste blanc
pour le groupe l'est républicain
sur le président ma question s'est
adressé à madame la première ministre
dans le prolongement de la question
posée par ma collègue françoise gatel
madame la première ministre vous avez à
plusieurs reprises dans cette enceinte
jeudi dernier notamment lors de votre
discours de politique générale à fermer
votre respect pour le sénat et votre
volonté de vous inspirer à l'avenir de
ces travaux en voici une occasion à
travers un sujet majeur qui préoccupe
aujourd'hui les maires celui de
l'objectif du zéro artificialisation net
qu'on va donc appelé âmes et je peux
vous dire après avoir fait une trentaine
de déplacements dans le pays que les
élus sont en ébullition sur ce sujet que
distille que lausanne sur metropolis
notre pays une fois de plus qu'il punit
notre ruralité une fois de plus
également que distille ils disent que
l'êta abandonne tout le monde puisqu'il
n'y a aucune ingénierie mise à la
disposition de nos élus pour réussir cet
objectif est que reproche-t-il il
reproche au pouvoir réglementaire que
vous représentez vous incarnez de
revenir sur la loi mais c'est quand même
assez grave quand on pense à la
hiérarchie des normes pas encore
prononcé ces mots que le pouvoir
réglementaire retranche à la loi votée
que disait cette loi votée ici que
lausanne ne tient pas contre mais par
contre nous étions opposés à la méthode
descendante à ce centralisme régional
punitif que qui était proposée alors
nous avons fait voter une
territorialisation de l'objectif par
exemple nous avons voulu dès sera d'être
le plus souple possible nous avons
demandé à ce qu'on prenne en compte les
trajectoires des élus qui sont dans la
sobriété foncière depuis longtemps nous
avons demandé de faire confiance aux
élus tout simplement à travers les scot
kiffis vous faire qui puisse vous faire
des propositions personne ne comprend
pourquoi ces décret retranche à la loi
alors c'est décret est dévitalisé
puisque vous compter à présent changer
de méthode et prendre en compte les
inquiétudes de nous tous et des élus en
particulier
comptez vous réellement réexaminer ces
décrets et revenir réellement sur la
volonté exprimée par le parlement
pour vos réponses par les communistes de
la transition écologique il la cohésion
des territoires monsieur béchu
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur blanc
il me semblait que le début de réponse
ce que j'avais fait à la présidente
gatel permettait de vous donner une idée
de notre détermination je vais donc
aller un chouïa plus loin
vous avez pointé un certain nombre de
choses dans votre question mais vous
conviendrez avec moi que l'analyse de
ces décrets qui date du 29 avril a fait
l'objet d'un certain nombre de travaux
récents y compris dans cette assemblée
ça n'est que le 29 juin que vous avez
remis vous même votre rapport spécial et
les urique huit recommandations que vous
préconisez au gouvernement vous
conviendrez avec moi nous sommes le 13
juillet fait je n'ai pas encore
totalement eu le temps de vous répondre
mais en ayant été nommés postérieurement
à votre rapport spécial ne témoigne pas
d'un manque de diligence d'attention de
prise de conscience de la situation la
présidente primat a communiqué le 6
juillet sur le retour des 1242
questionnaire qui lui sont revenus dans
le cadre de ce que les résolu locaux
reprocher à ce début d'exécution du zéro
artificialisation net dès l'instant où
chacun ici est conscient et rappelle que
nous ne remettons pas en cause la
nécessité de préserver nos espaces
naturels et agricoles avec le zéro
artificialisation net à compter de 2050
le sujet de comment on y parvient
de traitement des disparités
territoriales des moyens
d'accompagnement financier votre
première préconisation sur la
pérennisation d'un fonds friche qui a
été inscrit dans le cadre du crédit du
plan de relance a d'ores et déjà fait
l'arbitré l'objet d'un arbitrage
favorable de la part de la première
ministre pour que à compter de 2020 3
nous poursuivions avec un dispositif de
ce type les accompagnements financiers
qui sont nécessaires mais vous évoquer
les questions d'ingénierie vous évoquez
la mobilisation potentielle du fonds
national d'aidé à la pierre vous
suggérer une un guichet unique pour les
élus locaux qui permet d'y voir clair
vous suggérer qu'on puisse regarder pour
des projets d'internationaux ya plein de
pistes sur lesquelles on peut travailler
au delà de la séance d'aujourd'hui
rendez vous dans quelques jours pour que
nous puissions avancer la volonté réelle
le cap donné par la première ministre
est clair et l'ambition est partagé
monsieur blanc
[Applaudissements]
dont acte monsieur le ministre sachant
que les élus locaux ont jusqu'au 22
octobre pour faire des propositions à
leurs régions respectives dont il ya
véritablement plus qu'urgence merci
la parole est au président laurent lafon
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la première ministre
et je la pose au nom du président
françois noël buffet et de moi même la
finale de la champion s league a été
marquée par des événements d'une
particulière gravité si le pire a pu
être évité
les dysfonctionnements constatés ce jour
là ne doivent pas et ne peuvent pas être
minimisée nous devons des explications à
ceux qui ont été victimes et je pense en
particulier aux supporters du club de
liverpool mais aussi à ceux qui depuis
ces événements s'interrogent sur la
capacité de notre pays à organiser des
grands événements sportifs notamment la
coupe du roulement la coupe de monde de
rugby l'année prochaine et les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en 2024 le
sénat à travers la commission des lois
et celle de la culture de l'éducation et
de la communication a mené un certain
nombre d'auditions pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé ce jour là nous avons
avec le président en buffet produit un
rapport qui a été présenté ce matin aux
membres de nos deux commissions effet un
certain nombre de propositions votées à
l'unanimité
notre objectif est clairement
d'identifier de manière précise les
dysfonctionnements d'établir les
responsabilités des uns et des autres et
de faire des propositions pour éviter
que cela ne se reproduise madame la
première ministre votre parole a été
rare sur ce sujet nous pensons qu'elle
est nécessaire aujourd'hui notamment
pour bien engagé la préparation des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques alors tout
simplement nous souhaitons savoir quelle
est votre analyse des dysfonctionnements
et les enseignements que vous en tirez
pour vous répondre
la parole les communistes de l'intérieur
et des outre-mer monsieur gérald
darmanin
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pardon monsieur
le sénateur la forme ce césar lui fait
messieurs les présidents mesdames et
messieurs d'abord je veux dire que nous
avons pris connaissance ce matin du
rapport de vos deux commissions et que
nous suivrons les recommandations du
sénat
ces recommandations qui sont finalement
en trois parties la première sur la
billettique avec la ministre des sports
à la première ministre nous a demandé
d'appliquer notamment auprès des
organisateurs et auprès de nos propres
organisations sportives ces billets un
passif la baie et toutes les
recommandations que vous évoquez en
termes d'ordre public s'apprend très
important de votre passage de notre
rapport à la fois pour passer d'un
moment on la police doit être moins
tournée vers l'hooliganisme mais plus
sur les mouvements de foule et notamment
sur la protection de nos concitoyens et
peut être à l'exception de la garde à
cheval monté donc peut-être si vous êtes
d'accord on pourrait continuer cette
cette discussion
la quasi intégralité des propositions
que vous faites je doive être suivis
nous semble-t-il par le ministère de
l'intérieur et notamment la préfecture
de police et puis le troisième sujet
c'était évidemment sujet de la
délinquance puisque vous avez évoqué
évidemment dans notre rapport un constat
qui était réelle puisque ce soir là je
reprends vos mots monsieur le président
de la commission non seulement il ya eu
des dysfonctionnements mais des erreurs
de préparation dont la préfecture de
police miss à l'intérieur et les mises
intérieur doit tirer toutes conséquences
et le sens de la réunion qu'on a eu
autour de la première ministre voilà dix
jours mais nous ne connaissons pas
encore le contenu vos propositions c'est
aussi le sens de la réunion présidée par
le président de la république la semaine
prochaine autour des jeux olympiques qui
concerneront pas simplement les
questions de sécurité mais aussi les
questions de sécurité et dès la semaine
prochaine à la demande de la première
ministre et avec la ministre des sports
ne réuniront l'ensemble des services du
ministère de l'intérieur pour mettre en
place les recommandations du sénat et je
vous propose si vous en êtes d'accord de
revenir avec la ministre des sports et
le préfet de police devant votre
commission lendemain de l'été pour
savoir où nous en sommes arrivés dans
notre préparation même si la comparaison
même si la comparaison avec les jeux
olympiques ou la coupe du monde de rugby
n'est pas forcément raison vous le savez
monsieur le président j'aurais
d'ailleurs remarquer que trois matchs
anges se sont déroulés au stade de
france avec le même nombre de
spectateurs depuis cette finale et je
crois que les choses se sont passées les
plus correctement du monde
monsieur le président la faune
madame la première ministre monsieur le
ministre nous partageons comme vous
la préoccupation de faire en sorte que
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
possibles est pour nous une des
conditions indispensables pour cela
c'est qu'on tire tous les enseignements
de ce qui s'est passé lors de la finale
de la chan sic nous ne doutons pas une
seconde que la france sera capable
d'être présent au rendez vous des jeux
olympiques mais pour ça il faut avoir la
lucidité d'en tirer tous les
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé le
28 mai nous tenons à votre disposition
puisque nous avons nous avait fait cette
proposition pour travailler ensemble je
vous précise juste parce que vous n'avez
peut-être pas eu le temps de regarder
tout notre opposition qu elles ne sont
pas identiques à celles du préfet cadot
et qui en a même certaines qui
s'opposent
merci la parole est président pierre
charon pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur calvin
ma question s'adresse à madame la
première ministre
à deux ans des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de paris de nombreuses
interrogations révélations quant à la
maîtrise de leur organisation
s'accumulent les conclusions du rapport
du comité d'audit indique que seuls les
risques financiers liés à l'inflation
sur le coût des travaux il soit
clairement mentionné alors même que
l'explosion de certaines factures le
centre aquatique olympique 173 millions
au lieu de 90 l'aréna de la porte de la
chapelle 132 millions au lieu de 90
n'ont rien à voir avec ces inflations
tout comme les coûts engendrés par des
changements de site olympique de
dernière minute
interrogations aussi sur les questions
de sécurité publique parmi ces risques
figurent ceux pesant sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture sur la scène avec la
sécurisation sur plus de 6 kilomètres de
160 barge flottante
205 délégations étrangères dix mille
athlètes sans compter la présence de
nombreux chefs d'état et tout cela
devant 600 mille spectateurs
interrogations enfin sur la manière dont
la ville de paris gère ses jeux à ce
jour pas moins de cinq mille chantiers
gangrène la capitale de nombreux élus
parisiens avec l'âme davantage de
transparence dans la gestion de ce
dossier des jo sans réponse de la maire
de paris même l'ancien ministre champion
olympique guy drut alerte sur les
risques d'explosion de coûts et le
manque de concertation d'un budget
initial de 6 8 milliards d'euros celui
ci s'élève aujourd'hui à presque 8
milliards et ne tient pas compte de la
garantie des 3 milliards apportés par
l'état il s'agit d'éviter que cette
grande fête populaire ne se transforme
en un immense fiasco
aussi prouver vous madame la première
ministre confirmé que le gouvernement a
pris la pleine mesure de ce dossier et
qu'il veille à sécuriser le cadre
budgétaire et financier des jeux comme
l'a réclamé la cour des comptes je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
communiste de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
béchu
monsieur le président charron merci
d'abord pour une question qui ne
concerne pas le zéro artificialisation
dette
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
vous l'avez dit paris 2024 c'est la
promesse d'une grande fête avec un défi
majeur qu'est celui la livraison de
l'ensemble de ses infrastructures
vous savez aussi le mode d'organisation
de ces constructions avec une société
qui est présidée par la maire de paris
seul idéaux qui porte l'ensemble de ses
infrastructures et de décisions qui sont
prises par la mairie de paris sur un
certain nombre de ses sujets et qui
entraîne parfois ou souvent les
évolutions financières que vous êtes en
train de décrire hors inflation
je souhaite rappeler que la situation de
la ville de paris d'un produit financier
s'est singulièrement améliorée au cours
de ces derniers mois et que le sujet
quand on regarde le compte administratif
2021 où nous avons une épargne nette de
60,4 millions d'euros qui est à comparer
au déficit de 380 millions avec une
progression des recettes d'un demi
milliard qui est portée à la fois par le
retour des recettes tarifaires mais
également par la reprise des droits de
mutation fait qu' il serait de mauvaise
manière se défausser sur le gouvernement
considérant que la crise des finances
locales viendrait justifier d'une
manière ou d'une autre le fait qu'ils
aient un coup de main particulier de
notre part nous suivons évidemment ces
sujets avec beaucoup d'attention il
relève de plusieurs cas dans certains
cas sur la gestion des chantiers je vous
avoue ne pouvoir pas une expertise
particulière de la manière dont les
choses se passent sur d'autres au
contraire le suivi les discussions qui
peuvent exister notamment entre le
cabinet de la ministre des sports et la
mairie de paris nous permettront sans
doute d'y voir plus clair dans les
interpellations vous nous faite cet
après midi et qui vont nous conduire à
regarder un certain nombre de ces sujets
avec beaucoup plus d'interrogations mais
je le redis
la fierté d'organiser les jeux fait de
revendiquer un certain nombre de
décisions qui reviennent de la mairie ne
va pas ensuite conduire à se défausser
sur le gouvernement deux décisions qui
sont prises un autre et chante le nôtre
suchard on vous avez quelques secondes
j'aimais liste vous êtes trop subtil
pour ne pas avoir compris la question
il s'agissait pas de me défausser je
parlais surtout est bien évidemment de
la mauvaise gestion de la maire de paris
la parole l'état
notre collègue michel monnier pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
monsieur le président du sénat madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues en janvier
dernier le livre intitulé les fossoyeurs
de victor castanet a fait l'effet d'une
véritable
déflagration dans le monde des ehpad
face aux manquements du groupe orpea
dans le soin porté aux résidents face
aux atteintes aux droits des salariés
face à la faiblesse documenté de
l'action publique dans la surveillance
de ses activités
le sénat a mis en place une commission
d'information
doté des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête avec mon collègue bernard bonne
nous avons donc mené plus d'une
cinquantaine d'auditions nous avons
écouté les dirigeants d'orpea nous avons
auditionné le gouvernement les corps de
contrôle les financeurs que sont les ars
les départements ce rapport mes chers
collègues a été présenté hier en
commission des affaires sociales est
votée à l'unanimité
alors monsieur le ministre de l'
autonomie ma question est simple et
demande une réponse simple le
gouvernement va-t-il prendre à bras le
corps la question du grand âge et de la
perte d'autonomie le gouvernement
va-t-il nous proposer un projet de loi
pour vous répondre je vais appeler
monsieur le ministre des solidarités
l'autonomie à des personnes handicapées
jean christophe combes la parole
monsieur le ministre
si monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice michel munier
d'abord je vous remercie de me donner
l'opportunité de répondre à cette
première question pour moi est de le
faire ici dans cette assemblée que que
je connais bien et avec laquelle j'aurai
plaisir à travailler sur l'ensemble des
sujets de mon champ ils sont nombreux à
reposer sur les compétences des
collectivités locales dont vous êtes les
représentants et j'aurai aussi à coeur
d'entretenir un dialogue permanent
transparent et de qualité avec avec les
collectivités
vous l'avez dit les urgences sont
nombreuses pour pour le secteur je
connais parfaitement les attentes des
personnes accompagnées des familles des
professionnels aussi dont je tiens à
saluer l'engagement constant
particulièrement dans cette période
difficile c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle j'ai eu l'occasion de me
rendre pour mon premier déplacement dans
un ehpad la semaine dernière dans le val
d'oise pourrait pour annoncer un plan
pour cet été pour assurer la continuité
la prise en charge la continuité la
prise en charge médicale aussi auprès
des personnes âgées vous l'avez dit le
scandale orpea nous pose un défi immense
et nous rappelle combien la sécurité la
qualité de l'accueil des personnes âgées
dans ces établissements doit être une
priorité pour nous j'aurai à coeur
évidemment de reprendre l'ensemble des
mesures qui ont d'ores et déjà été
annoncées par ma prédécesseure madame
bourguignon est notamment engagée à ce
que d'ici deux ans l'ensemble des ehpad
dans notre pays les 7500 ehpad soit
contrôlée et donc nous renforcerons
encore les moyens d ars pour ce faire
j'aurai à coeur aussi d'améliorer les
systèmes et le suivi des signalements au
sein des ehpad de d'encourager et
d'engager plus fortement les familles à
participer à la vie des établissements
et à travailler de façon structurelle
aux problématiques de recrutement que le
secteur connaît je porte aussi une
vision une vision forte de la société du
bien vieillir une vision qui est celle
d'une société qui fait du grand âge une
capacité plutôt qu'une incapacité qui
perd mur et donne le droit d'agir ou aux
personnes et j'aurai plaisir à prendre
connaissance de votre rapport dont je
n'ai pas encore entendu les conclusions
et à travailler à les mettre en oeuvre
avec vous merci madame meunier
merci le monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse et et vos propos je ne doute pas
il ne mettons pas du tout en doute
l'intérêt que vous portez pour le sujet
mais entendez l'urgence entendez
l'urgence des professionnels qui le
manifestent depuis fort longtemps
entendez aussi l'urgence des familles
qui sont peut-être plus en demande
encore depuis la crise sanitaire et
qu'ils ne peuvent pas attendre
le statu quo c'est plus possible
monsieur le ministre il nous faut un
cadre de loi merci de me donner la
parole à notre collègue laurent burgoa
pour le groupe est républicain
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre y à quelques jours
d'un département du gard le feu a
consumé 900 hectares en près de 24
heures bordés ac bessèges gagnières
générac ou encore alès n'ont pas été
épargnés aujourd'hui le nombre gardois
s'apprêtent à vivre leur était avec
l'angoissé permanente de ces flammes je
veux rendre ici un hommage appuyé aux
sapeurs pompiers mobilisés
c'est grâce à leur bravoure et à la
réactivité des maires concernés qu
aucune habitation n'a été touchée un
lien avec le sous préfet
d'arrondissement
reste que ces feux s'ils peuvent être
des drames humains sont toujours un
désastre écologique
monsieur le ministre il faut absolument
adapter nos textes à nos territoires en
effet il arrive qu'au nom de la
biodiversité des élus départementaux ou
municipaux ne peuvent débroussailler les
abords des routes comme il le
souhaiterait est ce enfin de faire et ce
afin d'en faire de véritables coupe feu
il faut davantage laisser les préfets
concilier ces deux objectifs
qui je tiens alors aux dires ne sont pas
antinomiques surtout nos communes
rurales peuvent s'étendre sur de
nombreux hectares et ses communes
gardoises ne peuvent assumer seul ce
risque qui malheureusement est amené à
simplifier le débroussaillement à un
couteau si important que son utilité
tout comme l'entretien des voies dsi ou
encore les vigies monsieur le ministre
vous en conviendrez les feux coïncidera
romain avec les limites administratives
et cette lutte contre les incendies doit
pouvoir compter sur le soutien total de
l'état allez vous renforcer les moyens
financiers des collectivités concernées
par sa télé à feu je vous remercie pour
vous répondre à la parole et communistes
de l'intérieur monsieur norman à
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'abord je voudrais comme vous
dans le gard comme en ce moment en
gironde et comme partout ce territoire
national et pas simplement au sud de la
loire mais désormais nombreux feux
désormais sont au dessus de la loire
rendre hommage aux services de l'état
aux sapeurs pompiers aux gendarmes et
policiers aux élus locaux souvent aux
maires des communes rurales qui risque
de leur vie préviennent des populations
organisé secours et lutte des jours et
des nuits contre ces feux et votre
témoignage pour votre département
durement touchée voilà quelques jours
comme la gironde où je vais me rendre
dans quelques instants et je sais celui
de la nation toute entière alors il ya
deux types de réponse à votre question
monsieur le sénateur d'abord il ya une
question d'aménagement pour éviter que
ces feu ne se propage et si nous avons
été particulièrement meurtrier pour la
forêt puisque on a quasiment cinq mille
hectares de brûlé au moment où la
dernière à la même date n'étions qu'à
500 hectares de brûler c'est avant tout
du fait de la sécheresse parce que
depuis ces cinq dernières années nous
avons en moyenne - d'hectares de feu
grâce notamment à l'organisation des 10
des départements bien évidemment des
moyens technologiques de météo france
que je remercie je remercie le ministre
béchu et c'est super calculateur mais
aussi un investissement que nous mettons
grâce à l'union européenne puisque 90%
des canadair deux dash et des
hélicoptères qui arrive d'ailleurs dans
les prochaines semaines à la base de
nîmes sont payés par l'union européenne
mais aussi un aménagement comme vous
l'avez vous mais veut évoquer du fait
peut-être du réchauffement climatique à
revoir hélas le ministre en charge la
transition écologique eux travaillent
avec les miss à l'intérieur et les
départements puisqu'il est en plus en
charge de la cohésion territoriale
évidemment pour résoudre l'équation que
vous avez évoqué à la fois bien sûr le
souci de la biodiversité mais en même
temps éviter que des feux se propage
dans des conditions qui aujourd'hui se
font qu'il se propage de plus en plus
rapidement je terminerai monsieur le
président du sénat pour redire skalli
marc fesneau très justement 9e sur 10
sont d'origine humaine soit parce que
nos comportements nos comportements font
naître ces feux sur une aire d'autoroute
les français partent en vacances en ce
moment même lorsqu'on fait un barbecue
sauvage qui est interdit bien évidemment
soit parce qu'il ya des pyromanes et je
veux ici redire devant le ministre de la
justice garde des sceaux que c'est une
condamnation de dix ans de prison que de
mettre le feu à une forêt
malheureusement de très nombreux feux
sont d'origine humaine donc oui à
l'aménagement rural mais également au
comportement humain qui est responsable
de neuf sur dix sur burgoa vous avez
quelques secondes oui merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur mise avoir
rendu hommage aux sapeurs pompiers mais
ma question était de savoir si vous
allez accorder une aide supplémentaire
financière aux élus locaux et là
malheureusement je n'ai pas eu de
réponse vous savez les élus locaux sans
s'adapter mais ce qui leur manque le
plus c'est les moyens financiers
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
amel gacquerre pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires le 28 juin dernier le
gouvernement a annoncé une
revalorisation du point d'indicé de la
fonction publique celle ci est
nécessaire afin de soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des agents toutefois elle a un
coût extrêmement lourd pour les
collectivités territoriales plus de 2
milliards d'euros par an cette hausse du
point d'indicé décidée sans concertation
par l'état et payés par les
collectivités intervient dans un
contexte financier
particulièrement difficile à cet
dépenses de personnel s'ajoutent
l'explosion du coût de l'énergie du
carburant des prix alimentaires de la
construction on entend également parlé
du désengagement de l'état sur les
contrats aidés peck et ce n'est pas fini
la semaine dernière votre gouvernement a
annoncé la suppression de la cvae soit
17 milliards d'euros en moins pour les
collectivités
pour rappel le président de la
république veut imposer 10 milliards
d'euros d'économies aux collectivités
alors que le déficit de l'état lui ne
cesse de se creuser depuis 2010 est la
majorité des collectivités ne pourront
pas faire face à ces dépenses
supplémentaires avec toujours plus de
services à assurer c'est une casse
programmée des services publics qui se
présente à nous
ce matin la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement visant à compenser les deux
milliards imposées aux collectivités
face à la revalorisation du point
d'indicé
soutiendrez-vous cet amendement en
séance publique et au delà
quelle compensation comptez-vous mettre
en place pour garantir aux collectivités
leur capacité d'investissement et leur
autonomie financière
la cohésion des territoires transition
écologique possible
sur le président madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame là la sénatrice car
vous avez dit des choses justes et
d'autres qui le sont un tout petit peu
moins d'abord sur la concertation sur le
point dadis j'étais personnellement
présent la concertation qui a été
organisée par stanislas guérini avec la
conférence des employeurs territoriaux
et toutes les associations
représentatives tout dans la continuité
de ce que vous avez dit on dit à quel
point il était aujourd'hui nécessaire
après dix ans de gel du point d'indicé
d'accorder une revalorisation à nos
collaborateurs dont nous vantons les
mérites et pour lesquels il était
nécessaire de faire un geste tout se
sont également prononcés pour le fait
que les choses se fassent en une fois au
1er juillet et pas avec quelques
mesurettes qui s'étale et c'est une des
plus importantes décisions de
revalorisation salariale depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années deuxièmement
vous avez évoqué la situation des
collectivités locales et je vous demande
d'attendre la fin de ma phrase pour
réagir la cour des comptes a year publié
un rapport sur les finances locales qui
précisent la chose suivante c'est que la
situation des collectivités locales est
bien meilleure qu'elle ne l'était il ya
un an est bien meilleure qu'elle ne
l'était il ya cinq ans c'est
factuellement vrai quand on regarde ce
qui a été le quinquennat on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya une amélioration considérable
du niveau d'epargne et pour le dire de
manière un peu triviale la photo est
bonne le problème c'est le film parce
que quand on mesure les comptes au 1er
janvier et quand on se gargarise des 6
milliards de progression d'epargne par
rapport à il ya un an on voit quoi on
voit d'abord l'efficacité du soutien de
l'état et les effets du plan de relance
au travers des aides ont été accordées
aux collectivités
mais depuis janvier avec la guerre en
ukraine
l'inflation l'annnonce du point font que
la construction des budgets
supplémentaires qui n'entrent pas dans
les
radars un titre ou à un autre des
magistrats de la chambre régionale des
comptes ne se voit pas encore vous avez
évoqué le chiffre de deux milliards cent
pour l'ensemble des administrations
publiques locales lié à la
revalorisation du point comme ça
commence le 1er juillet la somme est de
1 milliard et dans quelques jours à la
demande de la première ministre je
recevrai l'ensemble des associations
d'élus pour évoquer avec elle la
situation de manière bâle et pour que
nous ayons à l'automne avant le début du
projet de loi de finances une vision et
une trajectoire pour les années qui
viennent vous avez ici très longtemps
dénoncé le fait de faire les choses par
petits bouts on va essayer de poser un
cadre global dans un contexte où les
finances des collectivités locales sont
soutenables pour cette année mais mérite
d'être accompagné pour les années qui
viennent wenger vous avez quelques
secondes
merci alors non seulement monsieur le
ministre vous me répondez pas ma
question ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que aujourd'hui les compensations soit
la hauteur des dépenses imposées aux
collectivités
ça c'est la première chose et puis la
deuxième ce qui est terrible quand même
c'est que nous avons la pression
aujourd'hui de vivre ce que nous avons
vécu sous le quinquennat hollande avec
cette baisse des dotations de 35% et je
vous alerte là dessus parce que cette
fois ci les collectivités ne le
supporteront pas
merci
chers collègues avant de nous séparer
sous réserve de la publication du décret
portant modification du décret de
convocation du parlement en session
extraordinaire et sous réserve de la
publication de la lettre d'ordre du jour
le gouvernement demande l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour du jeudi 21 juillet 2022
au matin du projet de loi autorisant la
ratification du protocole au traité de
l'atlantique nord sur l'accession de la
république de finlande
la ratification du protocole au traité
de l'atlantique nord sur l'accession du
royaume de suède qui ont été déposées ce
jour sur le bureau du sénat
je vous demande de me donner acte de
cette de l'ombre
cette façon c'est déjà acté alors
nous pourrions fixé début de l'examen de
ce texte à 11 heures
et nous vous aurions une discussion
générale d'une heure
il ya les observations là vous pouvez
faire des observations
il n'ya pas d'observation il en est
ainsi décidé nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 20
juillet à 15 heures je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance mardi 19 juillet
à 14h30 nous rendre hommage à notre
regretté collègue olivier léonard je
vous souhaite une très bonne fête
nationale et la séance est levée